what did you get up to last night
[ __ ] me and this dude got [ __ ] gay
dude oh jesus i didn't know you guys
were oh no man we were just drinking
no that was cal after uh that last
euphoria
wait don't
right now dude
what the [ __ ] i do your homework i i
tried to watch it last night we watched
it on youtube tv
and those [ __ ]
don't look at me like that it's sick all
right you guys don't support youtube tv
uh no i do because they're probably
watching it well they [ __ ] me because
i couldn't watch it last night so what's
your excuse youtube tv youtube tv is all
[ __ ] awesome you don't need cable if
you get youtube tv because it's
everything in like one service cool
brand deal man are we cut in on this
this is not a promotion we're not
getting paid for this sure we just like
the service and if we sign up with your
own ones
i mean i do have a promo code that you
can sign up with
well
it's not an argument anymore to get a
streaming service you don't need cable i
[ __ ] know i know i don't have cable
no i don't know
okay see the thing is it's ugh
you know what i don't know why
you guys anyways now
if you've been on twitter at all the
past couple days you've seen probably
every spoiler for the episode and
nothing really happened in the show you
disagree you're missing out on social
media right now i'm with brooke yeah
that was
that was huge but i wasn't referring to
his well that was a prosthetic i looked
it up you know i know i'm i'm i'm bummed
about that yeah so all the dicks are
fake
no no no no no no no no no no no yes yes
no no no no no no no no no the locker
room scene no yes they're off no they're
not no the locker room scene must have
been real because yeah and i came out
that with absolutely no you came in no
fact
no i i've double checked on what's
prosthetic and what's not and that's how
you know how much people are getting
paid connor's been researching this
there's a lot of dicks and like i was
going to say the dick when the guy sat
down to take a dump that must have been
real it was like that's the way it moved
that was a prosthetic dick yeah i looked
it up i don't know what's real anymore
euphoria is just like really the body
image situation on euphoria is just like
setting personally me up for failure
yeah imagine how i feel no i actually
agree with you guys everyone on there is
like so hot it's just like unrealistic
like like dominic fike like who has face
tattoos in high school
in person
who plays nate and it was like
like you can't even look at it my mouth
was a game like i was gaping in so many
ways
for jacob like it is it is just he is
like so scary good looking don't you get
like the vibe that he's like a gigantic
douche no offense i don't know if you
know jacob you were watching this jacob
i'm on the show dude what are you saying
you're a [ __ ] joke
he's saying he was
so nice and cool he was yeah if i was
jay balordi i would literally have
a shirt on i would like float everywhere
i feel like like i wouldn't walk don't
you think that [ __ ] like an angel
[ __ ] [ __ ] post meme where they like
to play cardi's music is just that
person like floating on the back that's
right yeah that's just what you do
around town no he was he was really
really [ __ ] cool he was really nice
but
yeah you get the vibe like when i watch
him and he does those like faces where
they're looking at like cassie from this
you know that in the first episode i was
having trouble watching that because i
feel like he's actually that person he
like plays that character too well
acting is like a key part of
tv shows
like it's easy to forget yeah i think i
just unplugged the mic yeah now let's
keep it let's keep it unplugged cody i
don't know if you know um no one on the
show was real and uh the not all the
penises are real okay
that's good to know i have to say you
know cody's old because that they use
the cable
line to sell you on it
old enough that you read like oh yeah no
cable and then
you completely got hoodwinked because no
one's had cable for [ __ ]
dude i know that but like sports
yeah how do you watch sports
uh you still need cable for that hulu
you can't live stream hulu has live
sports yeah you can do that
baker male may feel drilled that into
our brains yeah all right never mind so
hulu has live sports
it's okay we can
we'll figure this out yeah we'll start
we'll we can sidebar this we can help
you get on yeah if you wouldn't mind
helping me sign up for hbo yeah we can
take the dish off of your house can i
explain a little bit okay so we use
kelsey's dad's account because like
directv he has it so he gets everything
right i think he changed his password so
we're like sitting there and like i
don't want to sign up for [ __ ] hbo
and hulu right now and all these
services that we used so we're like
youtube tv has everything in one place
why don't we just sign up for this it's
like 60 bucks a month and then we get
everything got it
that's not that old is it
my dad has it and he was selling it to
me the other day was he it was like i
love youtube tv it has everything on it
you don't even need cable cable okay
might not have changed his password they
might have just like shut down directv
yeah man
i just also like the idea of cody
sitting there at home and every time the
dicks come out he's like that's real